jamie dimon said bitcoin is a little bit
of fool's gold i'm sure he didn't say it
for headlines at all jamie dimon is
obviously still skeptical of bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies now he is the
head of jpmorgan chase which now has
jumped into the deep end of bitcoin and
cryptocurrency so it's quite interesting
to see the leader of the business who is
not necessarily fond of the assets or
the services that the company is now
getting into in february of 2019
jpmorgan chase said it would roll out a
digital currency called jpm coin so
maybe he isn't a fan of bitcoin but he
was definitely a fan of creating his own
currency with jpm coin on top of that
october 2020 the firm created a new unit
for blockchain projects and in july it
was reported that jp morgan would be the
first big bank to execute crypto trades
requested by its wealth management
client and then in august of this year
it started giving its wealth management
clients access to crypto funds the first
thing i will say is do not listen to
what these people say just look at what
they do they say lots of stuff but at
the end of the day if there is a way for
them to make money on these assets they
are going to play in the game and so
going all the way back to february of
2019 they created their own coin they
created a blockchain unit they then
started to execute deals or trades for
their wealth management clients and now
they actually have crypto funds that
they give those wealth management
clients direct access to and so if there
is a way for them to make money on the
assets they are going to allow them to
participate we have three separate
quotes here from mr diamond the first is
it's got no intrinsic value and
regulators are going to regulate the
hell out of it sounds like somebody who
doesn't understand the assets and again
the reason why i continue to hammer on
folks like this and companies like this
is because what we are talking about is
they're offering it to their clients how
can you say something has no intrinsic
value and then turn around and offer it
to your clients either you believe in it
or you don't if you're gonna not believe
in it but then offer it to your clients
it brings up ethical questions why are
you offering it to your clients if you
say it is no intrinsic value now on top
of that it is regulated jamie dimon is
subject to less regulations in the state
of new york than a crypto company so
jamie dimon when he starts a bank he is
basically having to go in there he has
to get his banking license he's got to
go get his uh kyc and aml stuff
set up and lined up he then has to get a
broker dealer license he has to get
money transmitter licenses et cetera if
i want to start a crypto bank then i
have to do the exact same thing plus i
have to get a bit license i also have to
get a bit license in the state of new
york and they've only given on a handful
of those and so those organizations in
the crypto industry are actually
regulated more than the financial
industries if you're a bank you have to
get the bank license plus that bit
license if you're not a bank if you're
in the legacy financial system a fintech
company that's not a bank you don't need
a banking license but you still need
broker dealer license money transmitter
license kyc aml et cetera if you're not
a bank in the crypto world then you
would have to go ahead and you would
have to get brokered your license money
transmitter or license you'd have to get
kyc aml and the bit license so in the
financial capital of the world new york
city it is harder to start and run a
crypto company than it is to actually
run a traditional financial company
outside of crypto that is why most
crypto companies don't service customers
in new york think about how crazy that
is in this industry
many of the largest companies do not
service customers in the financial
capital of the world because of
regulation on top of that the asset in
which these banks
use to transact or support in fiat
currencies are treated more
advantageously by regulators than
the crypto assets for example if i go
out to dinner with the bank executives
and i buy dinner
in dollars i simply buy the meal and
then i pay my sales tax and that's it
that's how the transaction works because
the asset the currency is treated like a
currency there's no capital gains tax on
the appreciation of those assets but if
i go to dinner with those bank
executives and i use bitcoin to purchase
dinner i pay for the cost of dinner i
pay for the sales tax and i pay capital
gains on the bitcoin it is actually
treated as property even though it is a
digital currency it is not treated as a
currency by the regulations it is
treated as a piece of property therefore
the asset itself is more regulated than
the assets that they use on top of all
of that there is more transparency and
accountability in the bitcoin and crypto
industry than there is in the legacy
financial system we can see exactly how
much bitcoin there is in circulation we
can see how much of it is coming into
circulation every day we can see every
single transaction that is occurring on
a public blockchain and on top of that
we know who's buying it who's selling it
who's holding it how long they've been
holding it how much they hold etc there
is a fully transparent blockchain ledger
in this system if the legacy banks were
required to be half as transparent as
they would have to be if they used
bitcoin every single one of them would
come under scrutiny in scandals for all
of the nefarious stuff that they do
remember that most of the money
laundering that happens in the world
goes right through the big large
organizations the second quote that we
have from jamie dimon says i've always
believed it'll make it'll be made
illegal someplace like china made it
illegal so i think it's a little bit of
fool's gold now again
china is doing that because they are a
authoritarian
centralized communist country that wants
to launch their own to drastically
increase their financial surveillance
bitcoin is the most american technology
there ever is bitcoin is
anti-china technology so if we are going
to emulate china then we might as well
have our bank executives simply cheering
for our government to become
authoritarian communist countries which
would be absurd so i don't think that
you're saying oh china made it illegal
yes that is because bitcoin is a bitcoin
is a freedom technology of course the
authoritarian government doesn't like it
on top of that we have the third quote
here that says you can call it a
security or an asset or something like
that but if people are using it for tax
avoidance and sex trafficking and
ransomware it's going to be regulated
whether you like it or not the us dollar
is the choice currency around the world
for criminals money launders terrorists
and sex traffickers and that is a fact
that is proven over and over and over
and over again bitcoin is actually
ushering in a world of less nefarious
activities every single transaction is
on a public blockchain now do not think
that these banks believe what they're
saying they know that that is true
they've seen the reports there's very
very smart people inside the bank but
what they have to do is they have to
continue to hit their talking points
they have to be seen as risk averse but
again there would be much less money
laundering going on a legacy system if
they adopted bitcoin rather than
allowing people to continue to transact
in dollars remember this is financial
organizations not just jp morgan but
many of them who have over and over and
over again been identified and sometimes
even either fined or charged with
abating these types of nefarious actors
and so the legacy system is not a better
system it is not morally superior system
economic incentives drive the world and
if you want to usher in a financial
system of true transparency
then you have to use a public ledger and
that public ledger of bitcoin provides a
superior system for the legacy system if
you want to actually stop tax avoidance
and sex trafficking and ransomware and
all that stuff
then you would tell people
that you should actually use bitcoin
because it is a public ledger that
tracks every single transaction if you
are a criminal you are an absolute [ __ ]
if you use a currency where every single
time you move the money it is literally
written in an immutable way into a
public ledger that is how they get
caught if you talk to law enforcement
law enforcement wants people to commit
crimes with their fingers on a keyboard
because it is easier to catch them and
so of course the talking points from the
legacy system are all about these
already disproven myths about the assets
if you want to call it fool's gold if
you want to call it uh what do you say
securities and all this stuff we know
that this stuff isn't true we understand
that it's got to be talking points but
if you believe what you're actually
saying why are you offering your clients
the ability to buy these assets why are
you actually actively trying to create
your own coins it's because they don't
like the fact that now people will not
need to use a traditional bank you can
be self-sovereign you can actually go
buy the asset you can hold it yourself
and you do not need these centralized
third parties so this is the equivalent
of the person who sells horses and horse
carriages yelling and screaming because
the cars could be dangerous no the cars
just put the horses and the horse
carriages out of business and that
ultimately is what we're going to see is
some of these legacy banks are going to
be put out of business some of these
legacy banks are going to identify the
new technology they're going to embrace
it and they'll actually be able to
transition into the new world but when
you start saying crazy stuff like a
security or saying that it's illegal or
saying that it's only used for tax
avoidance and sex trafficking you're
simply fear-mongering because you're
selling it to your own clients